Speaker 1: All right, so we had two correspondents
at the Trump rally over the weekend in Conroe,
Texas.
We had Luke Beasley down there and we had
Josh Pitt and these guys did a fantastic job.
We're going to look at some of these videos
now.
This is the worst of the worst of what we
suspected was going on at these rallies.
In terms of the people, I put together some
questions for Luke and Josh.
You can find, by the way, if you go to YouTube
and search for Luke Beasley, Luke has a YouTube
channel.
Make sure to subscribe.
He's really doing a great job.
So let's start.
I mean, let's let's just jump right into it.
The first guy that Luke spoke to admitted
to going to the Capitol on January six, 2021.
I plain and simple, let's just jump right
into it and account for the fact that there's
there's background noise.
It was a wild and raucous situation.
Some of the audio is not perfect, but the
guys did the best job they could.
Here is one guy saying I was at the Capitol
on January 6th
Speaker 2: here at the Trump rally on stage.
We don't want to.
I hope we have a plan to get this.
Get our republic back.
That's what I'm here for.
I'm trying to find my son.
He's in this crowd here, but we didn't like
we were in Washington on January six with
two million patriots.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, there were not.
First of all, I would argue that they're not
patriots, but that putting that aside, there
were not two million people in Washington
on January six.
That's widely known now,
Speaker 2: and I'm happy to be here.
I walk about three miles to get to this field.
Speaker 1: Imagine walking three miles to
go to a Trump rally
Speaker 2: and tell me to go from the rally
to John Avenue, the lieutenant governor of
Texas and the Capitol Hill.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, that's crazy.
No, it was.
It was.
It was a great day until the end.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: So there is a guy who admits that
he went to the Capitol.
Two of the questions that I told the guys
we should really ask are ask people what they
think about critical race theory and then
if they say they're whatever they say about
it, then ask them what is critical race theory?
I also told them to ask about socialism.
It's basically as good as we could have imagined.
They're very much against critical race theory,
and they don't know what it is.
Here's Josh Pitt talking to the first guy.
And again, I know there's background audio.
We I think we can still make out what's being
said here.
The questions are what do you think about
critical race theory?
What is critical race theory?
Speaker 2: Take on critical race theory and
what is not enough?
OK.
Speaker 1: What do you think of critical race
theory?
I'm not a fan.
What is critical race theory, not what I'm
a fan of.
None of them know what it is.
Shouldn't surprise us.
Here's another one.
Speaker 2: Got you!
Are you concerned with critical race theory?
Absolutely.
It's got to an even bigger issue we taught
now that is being taught in some schools.
Some schools are fighting it, so it's not
there yet.
But if you go to your life in the United States,
you couldn't schools at a very young age,
and it's very sad.
Speaker 1: So it's terrible that it's being
taught, including to kids at a young age,
Speaker 2: and it will change its whole country.
What is critical?
What is critical race theory?
Critical race theory is a lot of things have
not done a lot of research on it, but there's
a lot of things that it is total race baiting,
teaching me how many algebra that algebra
actually means that LGB Cua.
Speaker 1: That's interesting.
I have never heard critical race theory be
called LGB Cua.
But I mean, listen, this this is someone who
is very much against it.
Speaker 2: That's not that bad.
Yeah, they're teaching sex education to the
kids.
I mean, there's just all
Speaker 1: kinds of stuff now.
Sex education has nothing to do with critical
race theory, but I'm sure you guys know that
with it.
Speaker 2: I'm not good on that.
Like.
Speaker 1: But yes, OK.
Then there were a lot of people feel this
is something a lot of people furious with
Mike Pence.
And in fact, we are now looking at a guy holding
a sign that says, execute pence for treason.
Let's listen a little bit here.
Speaker 2: You could have stopped it.
Could stop to stop what the fraudulent come
here would take, but I know that according
to the president, most likely to be executed
in the public square.
Speaker 1: So what just happened is this guy
is holding a sign that says execute pence
and then another guy yells that Clinton should
be executed in a public square.
This law and order, people don't care about
due process.
Go figure everybody to
Speaker 2: see, are you are gonna have to
get to be having this great country.
Let's go.
What's your worried about that?
Are you pleased to be OK?
Speaker 1: So now we move on to my next question,
which is is Joe Biden a socialist or communist?
And I made sure that the guys know if they
say yes.
You've got to ask, what are the socialist
or communist policies?
And again, it's exactly what we expected
Speaker 2: that you need to be a president
or hung like back in the day.
But you know that that rule was kind of changed.
So that's one squad if you want to.
Speaker 1: Oh, sorry, and we need that, we
need to actually move up to the so the communism
part is just a few a moment ahead here.
OK, here we go.
Finding my there's just so much here.
Speaker 2: So do you think Joe Biden is communist?
Yes.
Yes, yes.
He's so up in the China is naive and funny.
So based on what policies that he supports,
have you considered the context?
What do you mean?
Speaker 1: Isn't that the best on the basis
of which policy?
Is Joe Biden a communist?
Sorry, what do you mean?
Well, it's kind of the key question, ma'am.
Speaker 2: Are there any policies that he's
enacted or supported?
Well, he supports China, and that just sums
it all up, I guess.
OK, so the China president, not the Chinese
people that are being brutalized her.
He supports the Chinese.
He's been in their pockets and that's out
of China.
Speaker 1: So this woman thinks Biden's a
communist because he supports China.
Speaker 2: Communist China.
I believe so.
Speaker 1: So this now we've got another guy.
And if you're not watching, this guy is wearing
full Trump regalia.
It's a Trump hat, a Trump jersey, a Trump
cape and a Trump flag.
And here is this guy's explanation as to why
Biden is a communist.
Speaker 2: A week we witnessed, we knew we
were going to be against communists.
You know, which is why for many Americans,
you know, we come to America for you.
Speaker 1: OK, then we asked people, are they
vaccinated?
Most of them were not
Speaker 2: ready to get out.
Are you thinking about me?
You know?
So are you yourself vaccinated?
No, I had COVID and I want my immune system
and I'll fast to make that good.
Speaker 1: I didn't know that you could fast
to to to do something about COVID.
Not eating to deal with COVID, as I've not
heard that before.
Speaker 2: Absolutely not, and my son's not
and nobody is going to leave the Earth, you
know?
Speaker 1: And then lastly, we go back to
this guy who explains why global warming isn't
real, and he's talking about something related
to planets
Speaker 2: around the Sun.
Like one orbit.
You don't wonder, why don't you go, Hey, recruitment
low and fly the universe is a good perception.
All right.
So so the big Auburn game season that would
get us fly around in the universe one, one
four.
I'll be the whole circle.
So each region in the universe is different,
right?
And how do you change that?
You got to pray to God.
Speaker 1: I guess what he's saying is there
is no global warming because Earth is moving
through the universe and climate changes as
a result.
And all you can really do to control it, I
guess, is pray to God.
So as bad as anything, we imagined a major
success.
Great job by Luke Beasley and Josh Pitt, and
great job by producer Pat putting all of that
together, and we're going to do that again.
We'll keep sending people to these rallies
and your memberships help pay for us being
able to do that.
We'll let you know when the next rally
is upcoming.